Matthew Baker's taken a poo yeah yeah
Wow what it's a big one - Jen tell us
what you're doing this week I'm watching
both dogs and I already had them
yesterday for entire day and it was wild
this is Baker having fever already we
need to get Baker a bigger bowl because
his whole face goes inside this or maybe
he needs a smaller one because now his
hair isn't it talked to foods and drank
a whole bowl of water this morning so
jenna is watching Baker and Maddie while
Kyle and I are at Ultra this weekend but
there's such good dogs together okay
let's put on their their gear Maddie
what color do you want to wear today
baby
well color Maddie we're okay let's
more block cuz mommy's wearing black Oh
boys you're so cute I ordered some super
cute little nametags for Maddie and Bo
so hopefully it should be in soon
because I think what was going to love
it look at baby boy Baker in the back
seat
Jana took Maddie I took Baker and we
didn't want them to be in the car
together because we weren't sure how the
interaction would be so we're gonna have
to attempt that later bakers such a
precious little baby
he's a very very good boy
oh my Kenya holy moly Europe you're a
bass all right you go first oh you wanna
you wanna pee no you dude you're bad
you're gonna pee on him oh yeah he does
pee on him Oh God we're going for a
little walk and we're gonna grab some
breakfast maybe even know these pups are
why Jenna is gonna have one crazy week
um oh no baby pooping cheese Baker
you've already put three times today
Baker that's a big log honey
we made it to breakfast lunch it's 11:00
so I guess it's what I don't sure it's I
think it's still breakfast I get some
food and then I'm going to go get my
nails done and go shopping and be a
basic
I hate it but I don't have a choice
heading to ultra this weekend just be
really fun so I don't have anything to
wear other than sweatpants which is I
don't think appropriate I don't think
people more pants at all ultra so a
really a little overdressed yeah what do
people wear nothing but what was our
what nothing they wear like a sequined
bra top send like underwear is it okay
if I wear jeans and a t-shirt is that
okay wear jean shorts a nice tank top I
don't wear shorts I'll worry it's going
to be hot I have a I wear like a maybe a
nice I haven't oh I have that were a
little sundress I think wear a sundress
I'll do that I think I'll do that
everyone's like Jessie want to wear
something that they look I shouldn't be
able to dump on they rub on your bill am
I wearing dressing yeah we'll do that I
think I'll do that
are you to contango Maddie's gotta go to
work work or thrown inch without oatmeal
was delicious all right and good luck
you guys are so handsome so happy I
couldn't let
goodbye with Jenna alright let's go run
our errands oh wait a minute
he's Matias leash thanks cool see you
later
I found little Swabians basically yoga
pants and shirts that look like they've
been destroyed fashion in school
my birthday present here but you guys
remember years ago when I bought this
print and I've been meaning to get it
framed for honestly how long five years
maybe Maddie you're ruining my shot dude
anyways this is exactly what I wanted
holy moly big scratches large this
lighting looks great but don't worry
because it keeps changing colors and oh
here it goes I am just about to go to
bed because I'm heading to Miami
tomorrow morning for ultra I'm pretty
excited I've never been I think it's
gonna be great I am currently about you
when I link my rose gold Apple watch my
steel one is starting to not work so
well I'm not sure what's going on with
it
I'll show you this tomorrow Diana got me
this really cool rose gold watch band
dude my nails look sick in this light so
since dark actually can't even tell what
this watch band is gonna look like so I
guess I'll have to just see you tomorrow
Maddy's already sleeping I'm excited for
the updated watch os so that I'll
actually be able to just switch between
watch faces really quickly and you don't
have to unpair your Apple watch do you
want to think another one all right I'm
going to go to bed because I'm tired I'm
not really packed yet either so I look
terrifying
this is the site that will give you
nightmares I'll see you guys tomorrow
full of glory wanna mess up a video
piece we are on our way to Disney we
have a hot Disney date